We have a large home appliances customer who actually approached us
about expanding their portfolio to include smart applications
via an application on your phone or any of the voice apps like Siri or Alexa.
They found they were going to have to revamp their architecture to be able to support this new model moving forward.
What they're using IBM Cloud for is our middleware, which is essentially the glue
that holds all their software components together.
When you employ premium support, you have an assigned technical account manager that oversees your account.
And what the technical account manager can do for a premium support customer
is really coordinate all those efforts and really bring the right people in
but also you have prioritized ticket handling and access to IBM experts.
Which is something we put a lot of value in at IBM is making sure our customers are
comfortable approaching us and they’re satisfied after we resolve their issues.
Some of the problems they encountered was downtime on their network.
It’s a two-pronged approach when we fix these problems because we want to fix the problem
but we also want to make sure it doesn’t come back.
The multi-zone structure was the best way to get them to a stable and scalable environment all at the same time.
If they had any part of their environment go down, a device, an appliance
it could carry over to the next zone. So, there’s no danger of actual outage or impact.
And it really eases the concerns that a large company would have on implementing any new
products or new services into their catalog.
This customer specifically was able to triple their workload after they moved to a multi-zone architecture.
Anytime we're able to make a permanent fix and we can see customer business growing
or any positive impacts from changes we've implemented, that's always a big win for us.